BRAD GREEN: OK.
Welcome everybody.
Thanks for coming to the first
Angular conference or Angular
Meetup here in
Mountain View in 2014.
So we've got I think a really
good start of the year tonight.
I've got a couple
of announcements,
like I always do.
Then Victor's going to come
up and talk about Angular D3,
and Igor will finish
up with how will
pull requests work
in the Angular world.
A couple of announcements
before we get going.
Like always, if you plan to
talk, meaning ask a question,
and we hope you do, you will
need to sign one of the forms
that Igor has right back there.
And I think we give you a
T-shirt if you do such a thing.
Is that still true?
Yeah.
OK.
I think that's still true.
No pandering questions,
just real questions.
And I think that's it.
With that, we'll get started.
So, not a lot of things
happened in the world of Angular
in 2014, except we got a
lot of releases out somehow.
Apparently, we don't
observe holidays.
I think we've never gotten
so many releases out
as we did between last
Meetup and this one.
There's a couple of highlights
in these four releases.
There was 114 pull
requests closed.
A couple features
got in, like we
have multi-line NG options now.
There's one jqLite feature
for element dot one.
A ton of performance things
went in for injector, resource,
compile, parse,
broadcast, even in jqLite,
some things got faster.
And then a ton of bug fixes.
A lot of things around
IE8, a whole bunch
of stuff in the animation bits,
and across the rest of Angular.
In the world of Angular Dart,
we got out two releases.
If you haven't been
following along,
Angular Dart are the ports
to the Dart language.
And it's kind of
just getting started.
We're working towards
the 1.0 release.
Some of the things that we
added are getting parity
with Angular JS side.
So we're still adding
a bunch of directives.
There's new things
that got added there.
A lot of performance
improvements to make it
perform very well on Dart.
This is still a bit
of a new place for us.
And then we have some
experimental supports
for this thing called
shallow-repeat.
One other announcement
I'd like to make
is that we have a conference
going on in two days.
On the 16th we start
in Salt Lake City.
Anybody coming there with us?
A couple-- Just us.
OK.
Yes, one over here.
Good.
Great.
So this is for everybody
who's not coming.
We're actually going
to be live streaming
the entire conference.
You can tune into it live
and you can watch me again,
and some of the
other folks, talk
about other interesting things
in the world of Angular.
So please tune in.
I think it starts at
9:00 in the morning,
but that's maybe an hour
off in Salt Lake time.
And I'll see you guys there.
One other announcement.
If you are interested
in Angular on Dart,
the Dart team,
along with us, we're
running this thing called
Flight School to get you up
and running.
So if you want to
learn the Dart language
and learn about Angular
Dart on top of it.
This is happening in many cities
around the world, and really
around the world.
If you just search for-- Sorry
I don't have a link for it.
If you just search for
Dart Flight School,
you'll find it as
the first result.
And from Shanghai to Chicago
you can find a local place
where you can come tune
in and learn Angular Dart.
That's it for this
month's announcements.
We'll have Victor come up
and talk to us about D3.
VICTOR POWELL: Thanks Brad.
Can you hear me?
You're not supposed to see that.
So I'm a freelance data
visualization engineer,
and I'm giving a
talk, if you couldn't
tell by the slides, a
talk on visualizing data
with Angular and D3.
Also, all the slides are going
to be online after the talk,
so we'll pack out the
link on the Meetup,
so you shouldn't have to worry
about taking notes furiously.
We're going to be
going over a lot.
This is sort of the
combination of D3 and Angular.
So don't worry about that.
But before I begin, could I
just get a quick show of hands.
Who's in some way at all
familiar with Angular?
And don't be shy if you're not.
It's totally fine, because
this is the cross-pollination
of Meetups from the
E3 [INAUDIBLE] area.
OK, keep your hands up, though.
Keep your hands up.
Now, anyone that doesn't
have their hand up,
look at the person that does
have their hand up and talk
to them.
But it's a good turnout.
Nice hand raising for
a D-- Not surprising
for an Angular Meetup.
Now anyone that has
some familiarity with D3
go ahead and raise your hand.
Cool.
Now, if you're not familiar
with D3, that's fine.
Find someone who is and talk
to them, shake their hand,
say hello.
OK, now we're going
to get into the talk.
So little about me, because I
think it's important for you
to know a little bit about who
I am so you'll pay attention.
You'll know why to listen
in the first place.
I visualize data, obviously.
As a freelance developer,
I've most recently
worked with a company
called Monsoon
to help them build a dashboard
for Hewlett Packard that
helps them analyze
their data center energy
consumption across all
of their data centers.
I teach at a hacker
school in San Francisco
called Hack Reactor.
We actually have a few students
here today-- former students,
not current students.
Some of those, actually.
OK.
So I also really like
to explain things.
This is a visualization
of the central limit
theorem I did a while back.
Here's also an explanation
of the Monte Hall problem.
If you're not familiar, you
should Google it and find
this explanation, and
it'll tell you what it is
and why it's interesting.
Also, the Simpson's
paradox, which
is a really interesting
statistical anomaly--
I'm not going to get too much
into details because it'll
probably just confuse
you, but if you read this,
hopefully you won't
be confused anymore.
I'm sorry.
A lot of these
data visualizations
I've also done with my good
friend Lewis-- he's here today.
Lewis Lehe, or Le-- you
don't pronounce the H-E.
I'm also writing a book
with Ari Lerner, who
is in charge of ng-newsletter,
or puts together ng-newsletter.
And he's also written
the book, the ng-book.
This book is still in
a peer release state,
so it's not done completely,
but if you buy it now
you'll get a discount
over the release price.
And if you need help
understanding your data,
send me an email and
maybe I can help,
or the duo combination
of me and Lewis.
So no more ads.
Let's start to get
into the good parts.
So just to give you
a high level view,
this talk's going to be on why
and how you should use Angular
and D3 for doing
data visualizations.
Before we do that, though,
let's talk a little
about why you should
care about data
visualization in
the first place.
And to do that, I'd
like to show you
one of my most favorite
examples, Anscombe's quartet.
This is a series of four
data sets with x and y values
for each.
As a table it's kind of
hard to understand, so maybe
as a good idea, let's look
at the summary statistics
of that data set.
But when we do that,
unfortunately, they all
happen to have exactly the
same summary statistics.
How is that possible?
That's so frustrating.
The mean of x and variance
of x, the mean of y,
the variance of y,
correlation of x and y,
and the linear regression
is exactly the same.
And if we just look at
the summary statistics,
that's very confusing,
because all the data
seem somewhat different.
But it becomes
immediately apparent
when we visualize the data,
and we can see clearly
that the data sets represent
completely different behavior.
So, OK, we understand why data
visualization is important,
but why use Angular for
doing data visualization?
Chief among them
all are directives.
For those not familiar
with directives,
give us essentially
custom HTML tags.
It also allows
our visualizations
to stay modular
and self-contained
so that we can pick
them up and drop them
in to some other
application fairly easily.
But there's more reasons
than just directives
for doing data visualization.
Some of those we'll get
into, but for the most part
it's directives.
I like to think of
directives as input fields.
They're kind of like directives
that the browser gives us
automatically.
They're not actual directives
in an Angular sense.
But they are like directives
in that they encapsulate
a lot of behavior and
we're given a simple API
to plug into them.
So the one example right
here is the range input.
And I specify the min
and the maximum value,
and then the current value.
And then it, the
browser, handles
creating the slider,
and the knob,
and watching for
changes to that knob,
and updating the value for me.
I don't have to worry about
the internals of that slider.
It's just an input range.
Same thing for the
date input field.
There's really a lot of
complex user interaction
here that the browser
gives us for free,
but it abstracts away all
those concerns for us.
Well, wouldn't it be nice
if we could have something
like a donut chart
element, and then we
wouldn't have to worry
about the internals.
We could just plug
our data into it,
and not have to, after
having created our element,
not have to worry about how
it does all that it does.
Well, directives
make this possible.
Beyond directives, some of
the other interesting features
that Angular gives us when
we have our visualizations
and directives are
things like ng-switch
for conditional templating.
So let's say, for example,
based on some criteria,
we would like a pie chart to
be displayed with our data,
but maybe in some
other condition
we'd like a bar chart
to be there instead.
Another really great feature of
Angular that blends well, that
makes data visualization
a lot easier is ng-repeat.
Small multiples is this idea,
a powerful data visualization
tool, originally
popularized by Edward Tufte,
and it facilitates
the comparisons
of change across multiple
charts side by side.
So this is a classic
example of-- I'm
sorry-- of small multiples
by Eadweard Muybridge,
and it's called a
Horse in Motion.
You might be wondering,
though, why can't we
just use animation?
Why can't we just play a
video of a horse running?
Wouldn't that convey
all the information?
Well, it turns out--
I'm sorry, here's
a little graphic
I forgot to show.
Why can't we just have this?
Well, there's a few
limitations to this video.
For one, we're
stuck in the frame
of the playback of the video.
But say, as was the case
in this original example,
the horse is running so
fast that we actually
can't see whether or not
it's lifting its legs up,
or if all of its
legs are in the air
at the same time, which was the
original bet between the two
people that generated
this visualization
in the first place.
But another drawback
is that we're
stuck to only getting
an additional dimension,
but with small multiples we
can go over columns and rows
to get an extra two
dimensions of data.
So take this example
from Andrew Gelman,
which would be impossible
with simple animation.
It shows support
for school vouchers
by race, income, and state.
And we can really see some
really interesting insights,
if you look down
towards the bottom.
People with low income-- Sorry.
Let me backtrack a little bit.
Not surprisingly,
rich, white people
really like school vouchers.
But surprisingly, so do
poor blacks and Hispanics.
Whereas, white evangelicals
and white non-religions
of low to medium economic status
are the ones who oppose it.
So the map itself only has
two dimensions of information,
but the whole
visualization achieves
four levels of dimensions,
it's four dimensions of data,
by repeating the graphic
along the rows and columns.
So this is actually
really easy with Angular,
just by using the ng-repeat.
So this is a simple
example of a chart,
of iterating over
several charts,
and then creating the
donut chart directive
for all the charts that
we have on our scope.
We can even put ng-repeats
inside of ng-repeats.
Yo dog.
Because no one ever made that
joke at a program unit before.
So I have a little demo of that.
Hopefully it'll load.
It did not in your
window, it loaded in mine.
So here's the visualization.
It's life expectancy by
sex, race, and state.
And I'm just using
the same Mac directive
for all of those elements.
Let me see if I can show
you the Dom for this.
The window is very tight.
So this ends up being
what the actual Dom looks
like after Angular has gone
and done its dirty work.
And for every one
of these ng-repeats
there's an inner
ng-repeat that iterates
through all of the
different columns.
This example is
also in the slide,
so if you're interested
in seeing more about how,
in fact, this visualization
was generated,
just pull the slides
after the talk.
Also with Angular, it
makes it pretty easy
to do responsive design,
which is useful just
for web development in general.
But is very handy, specifically
for data visualizations.
I'll reload this demo.
And you can see that
as I resize the window,
the graph inside of it
is changing dynamically
in response to the
changes in the window.
Again, that demo is available
in the slides repository.
Another really great
thing about Angular
is it makes it easy to do
interactivity, basically
to hook up different
visualizations
so that they represent or
are connected in some way.
And so here is the
previous example
I showed you earlier
that me and Lewis built
to explain the
Simpson's paradox.
And see, when we drag the
sliders, the table of bar
charts and donut charts
updates accordingly.
And without Angular, this
would be rather tedious.
There's also another
more involved example
of interactivity
across visualizations.
This is the demo
application you would
need if you were
creating a video game
and you wanted to have
non-playable characters.
You could then add or
remove certain attributes,
in our case, web strength,
speed, and agility
for each of the
different characters.
So here I'll add a
non-playable character,
and that shows up
down at the bottom.
But so does its average
appear at the top.
And I can add multiple
different characters,
and it will affect the average.
So if I click on one
of the attributes,
you'll see the averages
above, updating accordingly.
Or I could change
the min and max
of the different attributes.
Or I could add
additional attributes.
And again, because Angular makes
responsive design a lot easier,
and rescale this window,
and the radar charts
will update accordingly.
So I just have one
radar chart directive
that I'm using across all
the different characters,
and also in the averages.
So I hope I've
sufficiently convinced you
to use directives when
doing data visualization.
And so, the next
part of this talk
will actually be us going
through and taking an existing
donut chart in D3 and converting
it to an Angular directive.
Before I do that, just for
those in the room that may not
be as familiar with
D3, I'm just going
to go through 1,000
foot view of what D3 is
and why you would want to
use it, pretty quickly.
But just to get you motivated
for learning more about it.
Essentially, D3 is a way for
you to manipulate the Dom based
on data.
That's where it gets its
name, Data Driven Documents.
So if we wanted to,
say, add or remove
different Dom elements that
corresponded to pie chart
heights, it would be very
easy to do that in D3.
D3's also very similar to
jQuery in its syntax and the way
it works, but it adds
a lot of functionality
that you would specifically need
for doing data visualization.
I also like to
think of D3 of just
being a collection
of helper functions
that make it easier to
do data visualization.
It's almost sort of
like a meta library
that you can use to create
your own visualizations.
It's not something you
would use as just a way
to include a bar
chart or pie chart.
It's really more
for people wanting
to create their
own visualizations,
not from some cookie
cutter template.
So just to give you an
example of some of flexibility
and power of D3, here's a
really contrived example
of just some data, the
values 20, 50 and 80.
I then select the body,
kind of like in jQuery.
I also select divs
that don't exist yet.
This is kind of the magic of D3.
And then I pen divs for every
one of the elements in the data
and then set its width attribute
to the value in the data.
And this is what a Dom
ends up looking like.
There's three Dom
elements, each of them
have widths, 20%, 50% and 80%.
So here's just a quick demo
of that code, and the three
different div bar charts.
Another great thing about
D3 is its collection
of these sort of
helper functions,
and one in particular that
I'll just skim over briefly
because we'll be using it later,
is the D3 layout pie generator.
And so with it we can take
data, create a generator, a pie
generator, and then path our
data to that pie generator,
and it will give us all of
the start and end angles
that would create a donut chart.
This is the code that
would actually go and take
that data, that pie chart data,
and create the necessary SVG
paths.
And SVG is just another--
It's just like the Dom.
I'm not going to
get into for now,
but just think about
it like any other Dom
components you'd
like to manipulate.
And we'll set some styles
and I'll pull out the demo.
And there it is.
It's in the upper right-hand
corner, so that's no good.
So we'll have to translate
it by some amount, so it's
in the center, or
so it just is not
in the upper right-hand
corner anymore.
And there it is, and
there's our donut chart.
So we'll be using
that code later on
to create our directive.
But just to give you
some quick links,
so if you want to pull it
down, these slides later,
and just learn more
about how these work.
There's an SVG primer, A Good
SVG Primer, by Scott Murray.
Let's Make a Bar
Chart, by Mike Bostock.
And Thinking with Joins,
also by Mike Bostock.
And I'll explain
some of the magic
that I went through earlier.
So now we're really going to
get into creating a directive.
So I'm actually going to hop
out of this mirrored mode.
And so you'll be
seeing what I see.
So there's a donut chart,
very similar like what
we had before, except now
we're giving it some color.
We're also dynamically
changing its size,
depending on its container.
In this case, it's just a div,
but it's not responsive yet.
So we'd like it to
be in a directive.
So how do we about doing that?
Well, the first step, obviously,
is we need to include Angular.
After that, we'll also
need to create our app.
Give it a name.
And it won't have
any dependencies.
We also need to tell Angular
where our app begins,
and also create our directive.
And so we want it to be called
donut chart, or donut.chart,
but we have to specify
donut, capital C, Chart.
And the directive
also needs to return
an object that has on
it a link function.
And this link function you can
think of as an constructor.
It will be called for every
time you press the stamp down
to create new donut chart.
And that gets called
with few arguments--
scope, the elements,
type it out,
but really we're just going
to call it EL for now.
And attr, we won't worry
about that for now, either.
So I just want to
test and make sure
that everything's
wired up correctly.
Just do that.
I'm going to add an
SVG to the element
inside of the directives, sort
of the containing element.
This'll be called donut chart.
Element we access
just like in jQuery,
since it's sort of a
jQuery wrapped object.
It's not exactly
jQuery, but it's
like a jQuery wrapped object.
So we'll need some
way to reference
that element directly.
And then use D3 to
select it, and then
a penned and SVG to it.
Oop.
But we should comment
out our D3 code first.
Ah, but there's nothing there.
That's because we don't actually
have a donut chart element.
Oh, but that
doesn't work either.
We actually need to
specify to Angular
that we'd like our
directive to look like this.
But this will be the type of
directive that we'll be using.
It will be donut-chart.
Obviously, there was
nothing there before,
because we're just adding SVG.
But now the SVG is inside
of our donut chart element.
I hope you all can see this.
So great.
Now we have everything we
need to be able to just plug
in our D3 code right inside
of our directive to have
what we had before.
But instead of selecting
the div directly on the Dom,
we'll just pass
the element to D3.
Actually, we don't
even need to do that.
We'll just do EL equals EL0.
But our width and
height is zero,
so why is that-- Oh, it's
because we have absolute-- Oh,
because we're not actually
selecting our donut
chart within our CSS.
We're selecting a CSS
class called donut chart.
We're not actually selecting
an element called donut chart.
So we'll need to change the CSS.
And there's our donut chart,
inside of our directive.
So already, we can now
reuse that donut chart.
So instead of giving it a width
and height of 100% by 100%,
I'll just give it
100 for now, and tell
it to display like a
block in block style.
And then we'll add
another donut chart.
Great.
So now we have two donut
charts inside of Angular.
But there's a problem.
We have our data inside
of our directive,
and that's just not good.
Because every time we
create a donut chart,
we don't want to always
have that same data.
We like to be able to
configure our donut
charts so it can
have different data.
Something like this
would be really nice.
The better example,
maybe 10 and 3.
It's hard to come up with
random numbers on the spot.
So that's actually a
really easy change.
We could just use scope.data
to reference the data scoped
variable on the donut chart.
But there's one
small little change
we have to make to the
object that we returned
from our directive,
and that is we
have tell Angular that our
directive will be receiving
a property on its
scope called data.
Oops, that's not right.
So there you have it.
We'll make it a
little bit bigger.
Whoa.
Maybe too big.
So great.
Now what would be
really cool, though,
if our donut chart
was responsive so
that we could resize
the window, or we
wouldn't have to always resize
the window for the donut chart
to fill the space.
So let's actually change the
CSS back to be 100% by 100%.
Actually, I'm going to
backtrack just a little bit.
Instead of doing
that, let's actually
talk a little bit
about ng-repeat,
which is what I was
talking about earlier,
and it makes small
multiples really easy.
So let's throw an
ng-repeat inside of here
and see if that works.
Also, set charts
on the outer scope
to be something like
some array of data
within another array of data.
So now we have this array
of arrays called charts,
and we'll iterate through
it instead of ng-repeat
for all the different
donut charts.
And we'll pass chart to the
data property of our donut chart
directive.
Sweet.
So we have these two charts.
Also, I just want
to talk a little bit
about using controller.
Generally, you don't
want to actually
be putting all your
data right in the Dom,
although it does really make
it easy to quickly create
data visualization.
We'll, right now, go
through the process
of creating a controller.
We'll call it donut
chart controller.
I think that's long
enough of a name.
Also have it use the scope,
and we'll create something
on the scope called
charts that it
will use to pull
the charts from.
So we're no longer stuck
inside of HTML world
that's sticking
with expressions.
Angular allows,
now we can actually
throw in Vanilla JavaScript
objects and code.
So I'll be using
D3 inside of here
to create an array of 10 charts.
Inside of each of those
charts, each of those charts
will have 10 elements
of random data.
This all right?
OK.
Sweet.
Now we've got all these charts.
They've all got their
own random data.
I'll also make these
a little smaller.
Cool.
Maybe give them 100.
So we're on a pretty
good roll here.
But now, wouldn't it
be cool if actually
all of our donut
charts were responsive,
so that whenever
we resize the page,
all the donut charts
would update accordingly,
and there would only always
be, say, 10 donut charts
on the line.
So to do that first,
we'll need ng-style,
and this basically allows us
to dynamically apply styles
to our directives.
Wow.
maybe not 100.
We'll just say 10 for now.
OK, cool.
And that's not so bad,
but it's not great either.
We'd really like it
if they would all
change their size, too,
whenever we resize the window.
Also change these
to be percentages.
So we need our directive to
update in some way, whenever
it's containing width
and height changes.
So to do that, we'll need
to do scope.watch, and then
give it a function
that returns the width
and height of the
containing element.
And whenever the return
value inside of here changes,
the second callback
will be fired.
And so this will handle
resizing our donut chart.
I see some closed eyes.
What's up?
Ah, where?
Width, client, height.
Thank you.
Good call.
So yeah, so inside of
here we'll do everything
that we'll need to change
whenever the client width
and height changes.
We'll also need to update
the width and height
to be those new values.
And now, we'll also need
to take all the things
in our donut chart that
depend on the width and height
and put them now inside of
this callback, because all
those things will
need to be updated
when the width and
height changes.
So just going down
from the top it
looks like min also depends
on width and height.
And the arc, the arc's
inner and outer radius
also depends on min,
which in return, depends
on width and height.
It also looks like the
SVG needs to be updated
when the width and
height changes.
And also, this inner group that
will translate the donut chart
into the center
needs to be updated
whenever the width
and height changes.
So we'll give that
a name right now.
We'll call it G, and
update it instead,
inside of the scope.watch when
with width and height changes.
So I think that's everything.
Whoa.
What did we forget?
Oh.
So whenever it first
loads, it looks
like they're all
set to 100 by 100.
But the client width
and height changes,
and we never get those
updates whenever it happens.
So we actually need
to also tell Angular,
hey, the window resized.
Someone resized the window.
Go check if anything
on the scope changed
and run all of those associated
watches for the client, width
and height.
So that's actually a simple fix.
We can just do scope--
inside of the controller,
we can do scope.-- Not scope.
You can have it
depend on the window,
and watch for resize events on
the window, and tell Angular,
hey, check for changes.
Whoa.
How's the method on?
Oh.
So we forgot to wrap our window
inside of the sort of Angular
version of jQuery,
and to do that we'll
have to do Angular.element.
Ah.
There we go.
So it's kind of working,
but still, the radiis
are not updating.
So actually, we also forgot
to apply the arc to the path.
That was the other
thing, that depended
on something that depended
on the width and height.
So the arc depended
on a min-- I'm sorry,
the arc path depended
on the arc generator,
the arc generator
depended on min,
min depended on
width and height.
So we'll need to actually take
that, you see this right here,
and add it to our watch for
the client, width and height.
Also need to give it a name,
if it doesn't have one yet.
Cool.
Now we have dynamically
resized, responsive donut charts
in Angular.
[APPLAUSE]
So the next thing you
probably might want to do
is have your data update.
Maybe we're getting a live
feed from some data source
and we'd like the donut chart
to always be adjusting or adding
new data points.
Well, to do that, we'll
first need the arc function.
And I've included the
reference to Mike Bostock's
original demo, which
describes how this works.
But for now, don't so much
worry about the details.
Just know that it will be
responsible for transitioning
our arc paths from one
configuration to another.
You also need to watch
for changes to the data,
and that's what this does.
Any time the data changes,
this functional will run.
And in it, the arcs will
be transitioned in or out,
and so for arcs.enter,
all of this
will happen when there's
more data in a pie chart
than there was before.
Similarly, for
arcs.exit, all of this
will run whenever there's
less data in the donut chart
than there was before.
And these will be run for
any past data pairs that
will remain in the chart
between the transitions.
So that's good.
But we also need some way to
sort of test our little demo.
We need some way for the data to
update inside of the directive.
So for that to happen, I just
have this little snippet here.
So any time anyone
clicks on the SVG run,
enter the Angular world,
essentially saying, hey,
after I do all these
things inside of here,
check for changes on the scope.
And in this case, we'll
be changing the data
on the directive.
Just some random new data.
Oh.
That didn't work.
Why did it not work?
Do we have an error.
Ah.
So I forgot to-- since
now the piece of code
that is responsible for
adding or removing arc paths
is inside of
scope.watch data, we
need to make sure that we don't
do any of that outside of it.
So, in this case, we have
these arcs, this arc selector,
and we're binding the
data, when it really
is not responsible
for it outside
of the scope.watch data.
So I'll just remove it.
And it may be somewhere else,
but I think that's good.
Sweet.
So now we have these
transitioning donut charts.
They start out with no data,
they get data, they animate in,
and they look awesome
because they're animated.
People love things that move.
So now, wouldn't it be cool
if, for whatever reason,
we wanted all of these donut
charts to share the same data.
We wanted it so that when
clicking on one-- well,
actually, let's press the
test if we can click on one
and update it.
We haven't done that yet.
So I can click on
one donut chart.
Its data is being updated from
the code that I've just added.
Every time I click, scope.data
is being set to some new value.
Whoa.
That kind of looks cooler.
So yeah, we would like
the data to be shared,
so just as a contrived
example, I'll
just add some new
variable to the scope.
I'll call it Our Data and
just copy what we had up here.
I'm creating a chart.
And now they'll all just
use that same shared
object, Our Data.
Sweet.
They all have the same data.
When I click on one, they all--
oh, they don't all update.
So this is sort of a gotcha
when using ng-repeat.
ng-repeat will
create a new scope
for all of your
different directives
that use the ng-repeat.
So if you're familiar with
object-oriented programming,
particularly in JavaScript
using the prototype chain,
if you have an object that is an
instance of some parent class,
if you set a variable
on it to some new value,
that property will
be that new value,
and it will not
overwrite the parent.
And that's exactly
what's happening here.
We need some way to prevent
our data from being overwritten
on the scope for
the parent property.
And so one trick to do that is
to just use sort of a shared
object, an additional
object on the parent scope
that will never get overwritten
by us, on any of the child
scopes.
Also, you need to update
it in our directive.
Oh no.
The worst error is
no error at all.
I called it charts now.
Ah.
I don't have it called charts.
I deleted this.
They had this up here.
Charts, actually, will
still be on the scope.
Oh no.
The demo gods will not allow.
I'll just chart our Our Data.
I'll leave that there for now.
Our Data.
Sweet.
So now they all share the same
data, so when I click on one,
it'll be updated across
all the donut charts,
or however many
we decide to have.
Maybe we'll make them 140 high,
and give them 100 of them.
Whoa.
So that concludes the talk.
I went over a lot, so if you
feel confused, that's OK.
As long as you feel compelled
to now combine D3 and Angular,
I'm happy.
I guess now, let me close
and go back to my slides,
if I can find them.
So now it's time for Q&A,
if anyone has any questions.
Is now a good time
for QA by the way?
OK, what, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
VICTOR POWELL: So it's on
GitHub if that's what you mean.
It'll be after the talk.
You can download all the demos
and the ones we went over.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
VICTOR POWELL: Oh
yeah, I'm sorry.
To repeat the question
he asked-- Oh,
I don't need the mic.
Just to repeat the
question, can I
put up some of these
directives on GitHub?
They will all be available
online after the talk.
You can go and fork the
repo or make contributions.
I know that some people
have been talking
about putting together more
comprehensive, a collection
of Angular and D3 directives,
and there are actually
some already-- Brian,
actually, put together
a great tutorial that
walks through all of this.
But there are
alternatives like Dangle--
I think Dangle, is
that the right--
But I think a lot can be
done, and a lot of improvement
can be made.
So I mean I don't know if I
could stand up and volunteer
to do that, but I
definitely think
there's a lot of value that
could be added from doing that.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: So there appears to
be some overlap between what
Angular can do and what D3 does.
So, for example, I saw
the bar of the code that
was in the link function was
creating elements in the Dom
and applying style to them.
And [INAUDIBLE] attributes.
And it appears to
me that part of that
can be created in
Angular templates,
but we can add those repeated
G elements inside the template.
So is it stuff that's been
tried are the advantages of this
[INAUDIBLE] to do that?
VICTOR POWELL:
--indicated doing so.
I mean there's a million ways to
skin a cat, as the cliche goes.
If that's a cliche.
I don't know.
I prefer to use D3.
It's where I have already
a lot of domain experience,
and I'd like to
continue using it.
But that's not to say
it's the only way.
But I don't think D3 will
be able to be removed
from the equation
completely, because I think
it adds so much in terms of
additional functionality,
helper functions that
transform your data in a very
convenient way.
BRAD GREEN: Victor,
we're actually
going to hold off on Q&A and do
a couple of lightening talks,
and then do Q&A with you,
Brian, Igor at the end.
So Brian's going
to come up, and I
think he's talking about
dependency injection.
Is that right?
So he'll be really
quick, like lightening.
Look how fast he's walking.
He's already lightening.
BRIAN FORD: Just a minute.
So I'm Brian.
I work at Google on
the Angular team,
and I'm giving a
short talk about-- So
this is going to be a
really, really short talk.
OK.
So Angular uses DI, and
one of the cool things
that you can do in DI,
or Dependency Injection,
that you can get a
hold of some components
and then modify it and
put it back in the system
and let Angular do
its thing with it.
So here I have a really
boring Angular app.
It's just two forms, and
it cotinates together,
their output.
But what we can do is we can
use this configure function
of an Angular module.
We can ask for a dollar
provide, and dollar
provide has this
method decorator where
you can ask for a
scope-- or sorry.
You can ask for some service,
so we can answer for,
for instance, the root scope.
It gives us this function
where whatever we return back,
Angular will use
as the root scope.
So what happens here is
dollar delegate is root scope.
They're equal.
And we can now change
root scope somehow.
So what I'm going to do is
I have this little helper
function that I wrote
down here called timerify.
This takes a function and
returns a new function that
first starts the timer, then
runs the original function,
then stops the timer, and
then logs the amount of time
it took to do whatever it was
that the original function was
doing.
So using this, we can actually
time dollar apply on the root
scope, and we can see how
long the digest cycle takes,
in effect.
So let's see what this
actually looks like here.
So if I refresh this, we see
10 milliseconds, type stuff in.
Angular's pretty fast.
So that's kind of cool.
And this is actually
the same trick
that battering, the
Angular debugger extension
uses to get into Angular
internals and mess
around with it.
So that's actually
the whole talk,
the code and the short
explanation is on GitHub,
btford/-- Brian talks
about decorators,
doesn't he in the repo?
And that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
IGOR MINAR: So hi everybody.
My name is Igor.
I'm from the Angular team.
And what I would
like to talk to you
about is about the process
we use to handle PRs,
and kind of demystify what
is happening when you send us
a PR, and how is
it being handled.
So you work on the
Angular application,
and unfortunately,
you come across a bug.
Maybe it looks uglier than
this one, or in a better case,
you have an idea on how
to make Angular better.
Way better.
And naturally, you go
to GitHub, and what you
notice there is that
Octocat has only five legs.
Like I drew eight, because
I thought Octocat, eight,
but it has only five.
Go to GitHub and check it.
You fork the project,
you craft your change,
and you send us a PR.
And then you notice that
the PR lands in our queue,
and there is like a
million other PRs there.
And you start to
wonder what's going on.
Do these people
handle those PRs?
Does anybody ever look at them?
Well, the good news is that
we are looking at them.
But there are so
many of them that we
have to develop the process
on how to handle them.
And I'm going to talk to
you about this process
a little bit.
So step one of the process
is you sending us the PR.
We covered this already.
The PR lands in our queue and
there's a brand new shiny PR.
The next step is triage.
So what we do is once a
day, we sit around a table
and all of us just
hammer on GitHub
and look at the new stuff
that just showed up,
all the new issues, all
the comments, all the PRs,
and try to triage them.
During the triage,
we review things.
We try to reproduce
bugs or try to reproduce
the bugs you're trying to fix.
Label things into categories
so that we have a better
understanding of what is it
that you're trying to do,
and what the change is about.
And then we move
things to milestones,
just so that we schedule when
we're going to deal with this.
What these milestones are?
Well, ideally we try to
merge things instantly.
But it's not that
common that the change
is ready to be instantly merged.
And it's going to be
obvious why in a little bit.
So it's more common that if
it's an important backfix,
we schedule it for
the current iteration
or for the next iteration.
Otherwise, it goes into
a midterm milestone,
which we pull things out
during our iteration planning.
If we don't have enough
information about what is it
that you are trying to
do, or if it's an issue
and it's not clear
what the issue is,
we have a milestone
called purgatory
in which we try to gather
more information before we
decide what to do
with the issue.
If the pull request is
trying to do something
that we are not
interested in just yet,
and we know that it's
going to take a lot of work
to get it into the master,
we put into ice box.
And hopefully, we'll
some time get to it.
I'm not sure when, but we
have this milestone because we
try not to reject PRs
that seem to be valid,
but they are just
not quite there yet
and won't be for a long time.
So Pro tip number one.
If you are sending us a
PR, aim for instant merge.
What does this mean?
Ideally, it should be a backfix.
It should be a small change
with good test coverage.
You should sign the CLA.
There is a script that bugs
you if you don't sign the CLA,
and the CLA process
is super simple.
And it should be obviously
what you are trying to fix.
Write a good description,
write a good comment message.
These are the best changes that
we can easily get into master.
If we can do an
instant merge, then
during iteration
planning we schedule
the PR to be handled
during the week.
And during the week we
review it more thoroughly.
We provide more feedback on
what is it that it needs.
And either wait for you
to make the changes,
or we make changes ourselves
and merge the change in.
This is done after all of
our check boxes are checked.
The tests have to be
there, the documentation
needs to be updated
if necessary.
We need the CLA, and
many other things.
All of these requirements are
upline in the contributing
documents.
So this is on GitHub
contributing.md.
You can check it out.
Pro tip number two.
If you're making a
big change and you're
going to spend a lot of
time crafting this PR,
please open an issue first.
This will allow us to
look at it and give you
instant feedback, if it even
makes sense to send us a PR.
Often people send us PRs, and
they don't belong to the core.
We want the core to stay
focused on the things
that only core can provide, and
all this nice-to-have features,
we provided it
through extra modules.
So, if you have
something in mind
and you know that it's
going to take a lot of time,
create an issue first.
Step four, done.
At least you think
you're done, but the PR
is far from being done.
Step four is actually
continuous integration.
By now, we ran
your tests already,
because Travis--
we have this set up
with Travis that will
run the tests whenever
you submit the PR.
But once we merge,
we run the test
one more time just to send it
and make sure that everything's
OK, no tests are being broken.
We actually currently
run two set ups.
We have Jenkins on
our own CI server.
And we have Travis
with [INAUDIBLE] Labs
that seems-- like
that's something
that we're trying to
completely migrate to.
But it's a complicated set
up, and to right now, we
run both just to be sure that we
are not without the CI server.
But hopefully, everything's
going to go well.
And we get step five,
continuous delivery.
Not many people know about this.
But what happens is when the
change gets merged into master,
we create a build and
we push the changes
to the recommendation side.
So if you are making changes
to the documentation,
those changes will
be available right
after the change is merged.
We want this so that people
can benefit from documentation
changes as soon as
they land in master,
so that they don't have
to wait for a release.
Another thing that we also do
is once a build is created,
we push it to bower.
We want people to start using
the bleeding edge of Angular
more, and that's why we push
to bower after every comment.
So every comment
that lands in master,
we create a build
out of it, we push
it to bower with a pre-release
[INAUDIBLE] version,
and you can fetch it very
easily and start using it.
This is not as
crazy as it sounds
because this is what we
do at Google already.
We take every comment
that lands in master,
we sync it into
Google, and we run it
against all of the applications
that use Angular at Google.
This gives us very fast
feedback on whether there
is a breaking
change, or basically,
if everything's fine.
And if everything
is fine, then we
sync this change into the
internal repository, where
within a few hours, all of
applications will pick it up
and will start to use it,
some even in production.
Pro tip number three.
Aim for greatest coverage.
The sooner we can
discover issues,
the sooner we can
fix them and can
avoid issues in a
later phase, which
would mean like we wouldn't
have to revert the comment,
or fight those fires.
So if we have a good coverage
for all of the changes,
this can avoid a lot of
hassle later in the process.
Pro tip number four.
Be mindful of breaking changes.
Like during stable
releases, we really
don't want breaking changes.
And if we see that something
has a breaking change,
it's not going to make it in.
We have an unstable branch
which will be opening for 1 to 3
very soon.
And we have a
process for handling
these breaking changes.
But most commonly, we just
don't want breaking changes.
Step number six is at release.
During the release, we
generate a change log.
And the way we generate
it, we take the comment
messages that landed in-- from
comments that land in master,
and we have a script that
will just generate it.
This is why we have this pretty
strict format for the comment
messages, so that we can
just generate the change
log, because otherwise, it's so
much hassle to create release
notes for every release,
especially if we
are trying to
release once a week.
Pro tip number five.
When you write a comment
message, write it in a way
that you would love
to read it, or you
would love others to read it.
This means describe the fix or
the issue that you are doing.
If it's a feature, make sure
you describe what it does.
But provide more in-depth
explanation probably
in the documentation that
is associated with the PR.
Next thing we do is we push
the bits to code AngularJS.
This is just an archive.
It's not a CDN.
I often see people use the
code AngularJS in flunkers
and and JS fiddles.
Use the CDN URL better.
This is really meant just for
an archive, and it's not a CDN,
but it contains
all the artifacts,
including the documentation.
So if you want to see what
the documentation looks
like at some version, you
can go there and see it.
Next what we do is we take all
the build artifacts and push
them to bower, this time with
the proper release versions
so that you get whatever
Angular 1 through 9,
or whatever it is
that we are releasing.
And we also push the
artifacts to Google CDN
so that you can get them to
clients as soon as possible.
We have Angular-seed.
We push the bits
in there, and we
have the tutorial which
we keep up-to-day,
so we also update
that on every release.
And that's it.
Like now your PR is in
Angular, it made it better,
and we are very thankful.
And we are hoping
that you're going
to send us more PRs that
are really high quality.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think we're going
do Q&A now, right?
And one more announcement.
We have a bunch of food left
over, and we have boxes,
so if you want to take some food
home, feel free to take some.
Yeah, we'll take questions now.
Victor and Brian.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hey, thanks
for all the talks guys.
Quick question for Brian.
Can I use your decorator
for route provider
and do something on
[INAUDIBLE] change?
Get a hold of
providers, can you?
IGOR MINAR: Get hold
of providers, no.
The providers are available
only during the run phase.
But for run changes,
we have events.
You can listen on run, change,
start event, and just handle
whatever you need to do there.
AUDIENCE: This is in line with
my question from last Meetup.
On every oil change
I want to select
kill all the Ajax sequence
from the previous page,
and kill the timers,
and all that.
So I was wondering if this could
be just a decorator that no one
else has to--
BRIAN FORD: Oh, OK.
Oh.
AUDIENCE: Well, I'll
continue with the events.
But I was hoping this was
handled without anyone else
having to do anything.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I just want you if
there is a couple
more ways to make sure what
I'm doing is sufficient.
More often than not, I see that
I put a console log statement,
I see too many things
coming up late.
Am I doing something might
reduce efficiency or something?
BRIAN FORD: Often, when you're
trying to debug something,
you see--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, let's
say, for example, I
was writing a validation event,
and then I see that-- Yeah.
Is it watching on too
many changes or no?
BRIAN FORD: We are working on
better tools to answer that.
I agree, right now it's not
easy to diagnosis, for instance,
why is something slow.
We're working on it.
And you can use techniques like
that to count how many times.
You wouldn't use-- decorator
is more like of like a system.
This you would probably
want [INAUDIBLE].
Louder?
There we go.
I'll just steal this.
So if you want to
answer the question
of is a specific
watcher slow, you
could use a similar
technique where
you're instrumenting
the function
and adding, and
stopping a timer.
But this technique
of using decorator
is more for like
system-wide changes.
Like if you want
to change something
in the entire DI system
inside of Angular.
Right now, it's perhaps
a little bit hard
to kind of drill down and
decide which things are useful.
But we're working on better
tools for that as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BRIAN FORD: Sure.
AUDIENCE: My
question's about D3.
So donut chart is
really cool, and you
can make as many donut
charts as you want,
and you can resize them.
What is your preferred method
for testing your D3 directives,
because they can overlap, they
might not update with data.
A lot of things
could happen to them.
VICTOR POWELL: That's
a good question,
and it's a hard one to answer,
but currently my CI environment
is my eyeballs.
For UI, it's very hard to
come up with good testing,
in my opinion.
Maybe there could be better
tools or better tools
that I could become
more aware of.
But it's easier for me to just
get immediate feedback just
from seeing if it
works or it doesn't.
IGOR MINAR: I came across an
interesting tool called Huxley,
which is a web driver-based
testing framework.
And what it does, it take
screenshots and compares them,
so that you can use that
for testing UI stuff.
And actually, like
it sounds crazy,
but the more I think about
it, it's pretty cool.
Like Huxley, check it out.
Huxley, yeah.
I think it's done by Facebook.
BRIAN FORD: So it's pretty
easy to test to things
like does this have a
given width or height
or some certain property.
But really, if you want to test
that something doesn't overlap
or something that
really looks like that,
tools that take screenshots and
[INAUDIBLE] them, or really,
I think, the only--
AUDIENCE: Well, the
way this tool works
is that you take a screenshot
that you're happy with,
and then you take it every
time you make changes.
BRIAN FORD: Right.
Yeah, precisely.
AUDIENCE: And when
there is a change that
doesn't match the
original screenshot,
then it's something
that you should look at.
And the new updates
of the screenshot's
a part of the review process.
So check it out.
It's pretty cool.
BRIAN FORD: I've seen it.
And there are similar
tools, though,
like it's not a new idea.
But you can do something like
that in your CI environment.
So that way you
still would catch
those sort of regressions.
AUDIENCE: Huxley, yeah, with H.
AUDIENCE: A question
about data feeds.
I'm still kind of
new to Angular,
and one thing that
I learned early on
is this idea of a promise,
where basically you've
got some data out there and
it'll come sooner or later.
Should I use Angular
functionality
to deal with data that might
be coming sooner or later,
or should I rely
maybe more on D3,
assuming D3 has
that functionality
to deal with data which might
be coming sooner or later.
BRIAN FORD: Or never.
AUDIENCE: Or never.
IGOR MINAR: I don't know.
I don't know if D3 has promises.
VICTOR POWELL: Mostly,
that's an issue
of getting your data before it
goes into the visualization.
And even though D3 does
offer a suite of utilities
for making that easier,
like D3.CSV and TSV,
I would recommend pulling all of
your data in through a service,
and then using that
inside the controller,
and then setting the data
you got from the service
on the controller, on the scope,
and then your D3 directives
will just plug into that.
So your D3 directives
shouldn't care
where they're
getting their data.
Just that they have data.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: This is a
question for Victor.
Your comment about there's
many ways to skin a cat.
Just thinking that I'm more
familiar with Angular than D3,
but it's clear that
there is overlap
in the kind of binding
area and things like that.
And you said you came from
your domain-specific kind
of knowledge, that you went
more with the D3 route.
Have you run across
anything where
maybe in blending
the two together
it overrode your domain dominant
mode of working, where you
found, perhaps, for stylistic
or performance reasons
there was a good
reason to change
the way that you were working?
VICTOR POWELL: I
haven't really run
into too many issues like that.
I feel as long as
you do a, if you're
very explicit about
keeping the boundaries,
that whatever goes
inside of your directive,
your visualization directive
should only be related to D3,
then you don't
really have to worry
about them clashing too heavily.
AUDIENCE: And again,
just more on D3.
Did you look at other
things that are out there,
or how do you compare
it to other things
that are out there,
and why D3 versus--
VICTOR POWELL: So the
good thing about all
of what I just showed you is
that you can replace the D3
parts with whatever you'd like.
You could manipulate the
Dom directly if you really
wanted to, but I would
advise against it,
and instead using
a library like D3.
But it's not the only one out
there that does what it does.
So you're free to use
whatever you'd like.
My personal bias is towards D3.
AUDIENCE: Why?
VICTOR POWELL: Just because
with D3 I can write less code,
and code that I can
come back to later
and have a pretty good
understanding of what
I wrote earlier.
BRIAN FORD: I
would say one thing
that I think D3 does better than
similar like SVG libraries is
that it has concepts that
compose together well.
Whereas other libraries are
more draw me a bar chart.
D3 gives you kind of
these different layouts
and these things and
lets you build up
something complicated
out of smaller parts.
VICTOR POWELL: I like to think
about it as a meta library.
I wouldn't use it to just give
you an existing bar chart.
You would-- [AUDIO DROP]
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question for Victor.
I was wondering,
I'm a big fan of D3,
but have you found
any limitations
in using Angular for D3?
And then my second
question is using Angular,
do you still find
it's necessary to use
NVD3 to have it modularized?
VICTOR POWELL: Can
you say that again?
AUDIENCE: So have you found
any limitations with using D3?
So did you have the full suite
of D3 library available to you?
And then second question is
there's NVD3 JS, which makes it
so that you can
modularize your D3.
Do you find that Angular
allows you the ability
to modularize without
the need of NVD3?
VICTOR POWELL: I would
say-- I don't actually
have a whole lot of
experience with NVD3.
I prefer to have
more flexibility,
so I tend to avoid libraries,
like NVD3, or what have you,
or any other sort of collection
of existing D3 libraries.
When I want to use
D3, it's not because I
need a bar chart or pie chart.
It's because I want
to do something
that hasn't been done yet.
So it's not really a
problem I can address.
Coming back to Angular
running into limitations,
I mean I haven't really
run into any major gotchas,
except for the scope with
ng-repeat that I mentioned
earlier.
I'm sure there are other areas.
I haven't fully exhausted
every possible combination
of D3 and Angular, though.
So there's probably
those gotchas out there
that I have yet to come across.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about-- here-- the question is
about Angular is about
manipulating Dom structures,
and D3 is also manipulating,
but it's inside SVG.
Have you ever tried to use
Angular markups inside the SVG
markup so that it
can directly driven
by the binding or the
brackets inside SVG?
VICTOR POWELL:
Well, first off, I
want to clarify that D3 is
not only just for manipulating
SVGs, even though that is
commonly used with SVG.
To address your
second question, that
was like the comment
that was asked earlier
at the end of the talk.
There are other ways of
creating data visualizations,
but I think there
is always going
to be at least some need
for D3 along the way.
Maybe in the future, the
features that D3 provide
wouldn't be in some monolithic
single framework as it is now.
You can already do
this in some extent
when you compile it on your own.
You could pick out the
features you're interested in.
But it does more than
just manipulating the Dom.
It gives you a
whole suite of tools
for manipulating data that are
useful in data visualizations.
AUDIENCE: So That is
actually, it is possible
directly using Angular to
manipulate the SVG Dom so
that you can change based on
the data definition or data
changes, right?
VICTOR POWELL: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: For example, I have
some paths, some rectangle
defining the SVG markup, and
I have some of the property
directly binded with
Angular's property,
like brackets, using brackets
to bind with Angular property.
So that when Angular's
property got changed,
the value in the SVG's
definition got changed too,
with it.
So it is possible
to do that without--
VICTOR POWELL: I think you just
answered your own question.
AUDIENCE: For example, I'm
defining kind of a path in SVG.
We are providing
several coordinates
in the D property of
the path's element.
Without using D3,
are you directly
referencing one property
from a scope of the Angular.
So that when the property,
Angular's scope got changed,
the paths got changed
in the SVG, too.
So that it doesn't have
to actually use the D3
to manipulate the
Dom without using--
I mean in your presentation
you defined a directive,
so do you watch the data change?
And then using the
D30 enter exit update
to actually update the SVG Dom.
I don't use this part.
I directly referencing
the data from the scope.
VICTOR POWELL: Can
you repeat that?
BRAD GREEN: So he's
just asking if there's
anything special
about the SVG element
and the way it's rendered
that would prevent you
from interplating an
Angular scope within that.
VICTOR POWELL: Oh, OK.
That's an easy question.
No.
Because the SVG
inside of the Dom
is just like any
other Dom element.
IGOR MINAR: We do
have tests that
verify that the data binding
works with SVG notes.
And if there are some
issues, then please
file them with all the bugs, and
we definitely want to fix them.
AUDIENCE: I had
just a short idea
that I can-- Is it common
to use this other thing
with like streaming data?
Saying if some backended
streams data to the front end
to [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR POWELL: You're
saying is that possible, or?
AUDIENCE: No.
If this is like a
common use case.
VICTOR POWELL: Yeah.
You could use it for doing that.
If you do it the
way I described,
the directive
shouldn't really care
where it gets the data from.
So it really shouldn't matter.
You could have a service
that's pulling data dynamically
from some API that
it's just updating.
And then the controller would
be responsible for updating
the data on the scope
and the directive
will just update automatically.
You could put the web
sockets inside of a service
or maybe there's already someone
might have already written
something that does
that that allows
Socket.IO to work in Angular.
But I think the
directive really should
have no opinion where
the data comes from.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, first
of all, for the talks.
They were great.
VICTOR POWELL: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question's
about interceptors.
So what are some other examples
where you would use it,
besides the timing, either
execution to run your code?
The first thing
that comes to mind,
perhaps, is maybe
role-based access control.
Would that be appropriate use
of interceptors in Angular?
I'm very new to it, so I'm just
kind of curious as to what else
you could do with it.
BRIAN FORD: Sure.
It was decorators is what--
AUDIENCE: Right.
BRIAN FORD: That's OK.
But interceptor's actually a
good way of thinking about it.
I like that.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I always con--
IGOR MINAR: But we also
have interceptors--
BRIAN FORD: Yes.
But it's important,
because there also
is this thing called
interceptors with HTTP
so you can intercept responses
and incoming and outgoing.
But it's important to
distinguish between those.
So you probably wouldn't
use this sort of technique
for something like that.
You probably have
some custom service
that you wrote that interacts
with your model data.
But if you wanted
to, for instance,
say I'm going to shut down all
HTTP requests across the board
if a user doesn't have this
thing, like dollar HTTP doesn't
have such an ability.
But you could hack your
own little API onto it
by saying give me
dollar HTTP, and we're
going to change how it
works so that way it
does something else.
The idea is that you can
change existing services
by kind of patching
their properties.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
Can't you use the HTTP backend
service, like you do in--
BRIAN FORD: There are a lot
of ways you could do it.
I was looking kind
of for an example.
Yeah.
But that, perhaps, might not
be the best way to do it.
But yeah, certainly.
IGOR MINAR: The
important thing is
that whenever you
use decorators,
ensure that the API
stays compatible.
Because as soon as
you monkey patch
the object in a way
that is not compatible,
then you might run into
issues with components
that expect whatever service
it is that you are monkey
patching to behave
in originally.
BRIAN FORD: Yes.
It's a very powerful
tool, and you
have to be
responsible and stuff.
VICTOR POWELL: I just wanted
to make one small point,
especially with
role-based access control.
You really don't
want to be relying
on doing that on the
client to begin with.
I think you mentioned that
a little bit, actually.
Fair enough.
So, responsible.
AUDIENCE: So I'm interested
in the book you're
writing with Ari
on D3 and Angular.
Could you talk a
little more about what
you find that's
interesting it it?
You know, sell it, as it were.
VICTOR POWELL: Well, the
book isn't 100% done.
Most of the book, as is, goes
through an instruction to D3
and an introduction to Angular.
But combining the
two hasn't been fully
worked out in the book.
But it should be very soon.
Some of things it'll be going
over, I went over in the talk,
or that will be going
over in the book,
I went over in the talk.
But I don't want to give
away all the secrets.